so let's talk about uh Trump and the
scientists I know as a
model and somebody that goes to
University of Pennsylvania and you're
about to graduate tonight your last
class are you comfortable talking about
this or could you get an F if you give
commentary on it so let's get right into
it Trump holds wider wide lead over
DeSantis among Georgia GOP voters in
2024 primary poll despite the
ex-president's endorsement flops against
top state Republicans last year okay so
this is a story from The Insider that
just came out uh let me read some of the
highlights of this story here so okay so
Paul of likely Republican primary votes
on Georgia found that former president
Donald Trump leads a former Governor Ron
DeSantis 51-31 51-30 in a potential 2024
race the survey also found that Trump
retains an average with the party's most
conservative voters as well as those who
are older and those who do not have a
college degree the Santas perform better
in the poll among Republican college
graduates and was competitive with the
uh Trump a monk a higher income members
of the party the polls show that 89 of
GOP voters said the recent indictment of
trump either Manhattan District
Attorney's Office over his involvement
in a hush money payment to the adult
film actress Stormy Daniels shouldn't
bar him from seeking the presidency
again what are your thoughts uh when it
comes down to Trump and the centers for
2024. I have a lot of thoughts um just
because I live here and this is all
anyone ever wants to talk about for some
reason
um I think the Santos is severely over
hyped um I think people really want to
move on from Donald Trump on both sides
even those that love him I think
secretly dream about a time where they
can go to work and not be asked about
their opinion on Donald Trump
um I think people think the status is
that guy because after 2016 people still
don't understand why Trump won and
really want someone to be the next
something and they think a republican
with five percent of Trump's personality
could do that they think the Santos is
the guy I don't see it I don't think
this is going to last I think the
indictment unfortunately it's probably
one of the first indictments Trump's
going to see we saw what happened to his
poll numbers after that and I think
that's what we're going to see for the
next year okay so you're you're 27
you're about to finish you know uh MBA
is it you know you're getting a message
you're about to finish your Masters
you're married you're living in Palm
Beach and New York back and forth what
policies what matters to you the most
today when it comes down to a candidate
so if you were to say at this age where
I am who I am this is what matters to me
you know I want to see this this what
would those items be for you those
policies be honestly it's weird if you
asked me six months ago I could list a
bunch and now I'm just like let's not go
into war with Russia and China like I'm
just scared for what the hell is going
to happen to America and I want whatever
comes after Joe Biden to actually
protect us from the world which really
wants us dead like it's that simple so
I'd say whoever can keep America safe
and keep a country in existence for my
future children that's number one right
now what's two
hey
um I don't think they're in order I'd
say foreign policy wise America First
very simple when it comes to in the
country I think
for example keeping something like
abortion like I consider myself Pro uh
life but I think keeping Americans kind
of stable and not arguing over how far
left or how far right we can be based on
whose administration is in power like
that's a normal thing that we should be
able to agree on I think the Santas is
too far right on that for example we
just saw that six weeks yeah
um I think I think Trump actually said
when I could be wrong when Texas passed
the six weeks the same rule I think
Trump said it was a little complex and
he wasn't sure if he agreed with it so I
think it was 2021 I believe yeah I think
a balance is very necessary I think
people really want to see the right beat
the left or left beat the right
depending on you know what side you're
on I just want a normal country I want
to balance I want Harmony I want people
not you know punching each other in the
street based on who they voted for in
2016.
um and I want to know that you know
people are safe the kids are safe the
religious liberty is safe just very
basic Common Sense American values that
I grew up with that I'm kind of scared
or disappearing so let me read that
story for you and and I want to I want
to get your comment thoughts on this
Florida lawmakers passed six-speak
abortion law this is a Wall Street
Journal story uh they have passed a bill
Banning abortion after six weeks of
pregnancy a strict measure that
indicates Republicans aren't backing
away from efforts to curtail abortion
access even in the states where such
efforts may carry political risk a poll
in March by the University of North
Carolina found that 75 percent of
Floridians oppose Banning abortion
starting at six weeks of pregnancy all
by with no exceptions of for rape and
incest the final hurdle for the bill is
a signature from Governor Ron DeSantis
who has said he would sign legislation
limiting abortion if it crosses his desk
if enacted the bill would ban most
abortions in the state and with limited
exceptions including for rape and incest
and for certain medical emergencies
since the Supreme Court overturned Roe v
Wade last year June roughly a dozen
states have banned most abortions so
you're not with six weeks I think
majority of Americans with not mistaken
are uncomfortable with that they are
yeah yeah it's that simple Americans
don't support this you know when you
want an America that's living in Harmony
and when issues are that serious and
that nuanced and that emotion over so
many people I don't think the whole like
beat the left beat the right you know
debate and wokeness and you know social
media going viral like all these things
that politicians are focusing on right
now I don't think that's necessary for
an issue as serious as abortion you
think that's going to be a big talk
topic of discussion for 2024. you think
left's going to use that a lot depending
on who the nominee is but yes for sure
let's just say an energized guy named
Joe Biden is the nominee and he's going
up against a trump or with the sentence
how different would it be
um I think if the santis is the nominee
with the six week you know ban I think
would be more prevalent but no people
are going to bring it up for sure I
think that was a big topic of the
midterms we kind of realized I mean I
see it going on on college campuses I
see what's happening with young people
and that's I'd say their top three
issues like abortion is one of them
colleges and universities that you're
talking about they're talking about
abortion yeah well don't forget uh just
during the midterms uh it was supposed
to be a red wave yeah right I mean for
months and months and months it's a red
wave we all this always happens the
incumbent president when the when he's
in there and the the the the there's a
midterm election and then what we saw
happen was a red teardrop basically and
so they took over the the House
Representatives they didn't do anything
with the Senate and one of the major
reasons why was this Dobbs decision
overturning Rover swade yeah uh you know
there's speculation that Mitch McConnell
manufactured this because he didn't want
to take over that's I think
this was uncalculated in a horrible
decision by the Republicans they should
have waited until after the midterms to
do this so clearly this is a major issue
especially for women now if when it
comes to DeSantis in Florida this makes
no sense to me because if you're if
you're if you're trying to win a primary
okay
um
you may be appealed to the base okay
maybe that works for you but we all know
that
basically the way that it works is
during the primary you appeal to your
base and then you pivot in the general
election to peel to the center
nobody in America there is no appetite
for a six week abortion ban there's no
appetite we can have conversations about
12 weeks 15 weeks pro-life poor
pro-choice nobody this is Draconian at
best not nobody it's not nobody it's
just not the majority so so it's not a
nobody thing when you say that and the
Mitch McConnell you don't know if that
did happen or not as a strategy nobody
knows that nobody can sit there and say
that wasn't the case we're all
speculating here these are our opinions
that we're given it's not 100 certainty
that we know one way or another
to do what what is kind of weird is
after what happened with Roe v Wade
everybody in the country already knows
where the Santa stands you don't need to
do this like this is not a a policy to
attack to get the conservative people to
say oh he's even more conservative than
I thought I you know I don't know if
this is the right direction to go but
you know he's choosing to go this
direction why do you think he's doing
this I think if you're if you're his
strategist if you're his chief
strategist and you're saying all right
you got to run to the right of Center
but everyone's saying the reason that
people like you is because you're quote
unquote left of trump right right of
trump why would you do this this makes
no sense to me yeah he also did it
didn't you sign it like 11 p.m in a room
somewhere he knows it's not going to be
possible he's not a stupid guy why would
you do this Pat six weeks
why would he do this yeah why would he
do this okay you're you're either doing
this because it's truly a belief that
you have and let's just say that's what
he really believes in based on his
values and principles they're thinking
this is going to get people that weren't
there for him to support him which I
believe he already has that vote uh
maybe it's a position to differentiate
himself from Trump to say hey I am not
like Trump while Trump is you know
casual with this and he'll go up to
whatever the numbers 12 weeks or you
know 16 weeks 20 weeks you know I'm not
going past six weeks could be a way of
him wanting certain conservative people
to you know tell okay this guy is more
conservative than we thought there's so
many different ways you can look at this
year I don't know strategically if this
would be the policy I would
touch if you want to become president
after we saw what happened on midterms I
don't I don't understand it
strategically either but like she said
he's not a dummy he's a very smart guy
uh the center you know who the sentence
is here's what the sentence is you know
how in a group text you're with your
friends and your buddies and everybody's
talking yeah and you're sending
texts and one guy sends a picture of
this and you know how we kind of send
stuff to we say stuff to each other with
guys that maybe you wouldn't you know
wouldn't do it you know you're referring
to what is known as locker room talk
well you want to call a locker room talk
with it I would do this I would do this
to her and I would do that man let me
tell you all this stuff like guys to
talk about he's the guy that would just
do one emoji LOL but he would never say
and engage that's him yeah so you have
to know who he is meaning this guy has
been thinking about this
since he was very young that one day
this is going to happen and he's careful
who he takes pictures with he's careful
he's that guy okay this is not a
trumpers I think I don't give a man
I'm doing this I'm doing that you don't
like it I don't know this is so there's
a very different style so if if that's
how he's branding himself
and he decides to get away from that
brand we already have somebody that's
away from that brand yeah your brand is
the opposite of trump okay your brand is
the safe guy your brand is the you know
this is the guy that we settle down with
we have that brand he's very safe but by
the way I think he's a strong leader I
think in a way this also helps knowing
he's probably careful with the decisions
he's going to be making if he does
become a president I think he will make
a good president I think there's a part
of him that he'll make a great president
uh later on it's just you know whether
people are ready with him being there
today and whether this was a good move
at a time like this I don't know you got
20 other issues you can pick and choose
from to go from you can choose the
Border you can choose economy you can
choose covet you can go after more fauci
you can do uh education you can go after
the trends you can do so many different
things this one's going to upset some
people on the right that are pro-choice
so this is and you said it there's a lot
of closet Pro choices by the way on the
right oh 100 Tommy Lauren made her name
there are people that will say I'm
pro-life but inside listen man I kind of
had to be pro-choice seven years ago
there's a lot of closet Pro choices that
none of us know about male politician
ever yeah yeah absolutely yeah but yeah
so Elizabeth if it comes down so so
Trump because you're you're involved
with the campaign right in 2016. so you
obviously saw it firsthand Trump did not
get a fair Shake I don't care what
anybody says before he won the
investigation from Russia the collusion
to during the swamp and the media just
turning on him nobody's ever seen
anything like that because they were all
they all bowed down to the powers that
be if it came down to right now are you
going are you voting for Trump or the
Saints if it comes down to that left or
right from descendants I would vote for
Donald Trump you would 100 go for Donald
Trump and what what and besides all the
like the thing that we just talked about
what what's your just from what you've
seen in the past yeah or are you just
sticking to your guns because you're
like he he he is for the people and he
sacrificed everything for us it's like
such a basic non- almost educated answer
but I just I hate politicians like I've
just been around them so much I cannot
stand them and he's a politician and I
don't like that yeah it's that simple
what do you not like about politicians
they're just rehearsed and much like we
just talked about the closeted
pro-choice people like they're just all
horrible like all politicians they'll
tell you what you want to hear it
doesn't matter they'll compromise
anything as long not a statement or like
a decision that comes out of their mouth
that doesn't come from like give us an
example give us an example of it of
somebody I was just gonna say like who
would be the poster child you think so
all of a truly what name did you say I
said to Santos but that's only because
we've talked about now anyone before
Donald Trump anyone asks well she's
saying because he's a politician like
Ted Cruz when you look at Ted Cruz you
look at Ted Cruz he just says what like
he's the typical cutout Board of a
politician he says what the people want
to hear you don't know who he really is
as a human being and she nailed it I
mean Donald Trump was a businessman but
just said you know what I'm gonna come
in I'm going to shake I don't know
I don't think Ted Cruz is likable but I
think he's a dog I don't I don't think
he's you know you know like I always go
back to if we were in high school right
to see who the person was in high school
okay so if you go to high school this
guy you kind of know who he was okay if
I go to high school with you I kind of
know who you were you go to high school
with Ted you know who he was you know
who Ted was yeah who was Ted Cruz in
high school it's probably on the debate
team he definitely was picking up it was
definitely a very unconscious he got a
wedgie a week 100 someone he's probably
guy that was so condescending making
people you know who he is Ted Cruz a a a
a movie character you ready I'm gonna
give it to you and you're gonna go there
ready ready go ahead Goodwill Hunting
how about them apples he's that guy oh
wow really okay do you know who which
guy I'm talking about 100 he's gonna
come in here and recite things that you
read online in that boom boom he is that
smart and he wants to make you look like
a but guess what he is still a dog
100 he is still a dog but politician
through and through I also understand
what no I don't think so you don't think
so no I think politicians through and
through to me is somebody that
I get what she's saying there's a
difference between a Statesman and you
know a politician there's still a few of
them around you don't have to like them
there's still a few them around there's
some of them that will sell their soul
just to have their career who would you
say right now if you had to if you had
to say politician that's the person
McConnell is a politician recounts of
politics I think it's for sure
politician I think there's a lot of them
out there but I think he's a politician
Schumer's a politician Pelosi is a
politician uh uh the problem with this
world is the longer you're in this world
the more you start being one and you
don't even know it it's that temperature
yeah look if you and I lived in a house
okay
and in this house we're living with 20
different people you and I are 22 years
old okay
we're expected to live in this house for
six months it's on the beach okay 10
girls 10 guys oh wow and it's a
beautiful house party house Jersey Shore
type drinks on the house everything on
the house
if 19 other guys in this house are
snorting they're doing e they're rolling
they're doing everything how long until
you are tempted to join the club 10 30
at night
the point is there's power and influence
of course so the longer you're in the
swamp you eventually they call this one
because which is why term limits should
be a number one priority yeah did you
see that guy give a speech uh he was at
the podium and he's like you guys tell
me if this is the NBA or the NFL players
you ever seen this piece oh yeah yeah he
goes all right guys give in to an
audience he's like you tell me which
sport you think this is the NBA of the
NFL is like uh 32 DUIs uh multiple
convictions four seconds go back put
them play it go ahead yeah yeah this is
a great I know what you're talking about
watch this oh this is oh okay this is
kind of validated
or NFL Elizabeth you ever seen this go
back go back to Chicago
by the way I I want you to guess before
he reveals it whether you think it's the
NBA their NFL okay
which is it is it NBA or NFL
36 have been accused of spousal abuse
seven have been arrested for fraud
19 have been accused of writing bad
checks
117 of directly or indirectly been
bankrupted at least two businesses
three have done time for assault 71 I
repeat 71 cannot get a credit card due
to their bad credit
14 have been arrested on drug related
charges eight have been arrested for
shoplifting 21 currently are defendants
in lawsuits and 84 have been arrested
for drunk driving in the last year
how many of you think NBA
how many of you think NFL which one do
you think Elizabeth do you think it's
the NBA their NFL you're going to say
like United States Congress yeah
it's the 435 members of the United
States yes there you go proving your
point yeah
anyway Congress Congress approval
ratings actually just increased five
percent over the last year to a whopping
23 approval we're at 75 disapproval uh
not great numbers no their Q score what
would it take to do term limits I mean
because the people that are they're in
charge of saying yeah the people that
are voting
but don't you feel like that I mean that
I agree with you 100 like I'm like when
you see somebody like Joe Biden
obviously he's the worst one but Nancy
Pelosi actually speak I'm like you want
to talk about embarrassed I'm like how
how
they're all the same they'll get Chuck
Grassley he's 117 years old no he's yeah
he died
out there just coming in and voting he's
a hologram you got Dianne Feinstein 98
years old well yeah I mean maybe that's
generous she might be 198. yeah she's
scared you got McConnell you got Pelosi
you got Schumer they're 80 plus years
old running the country boy Mitch if
Mitch McConnell's not an alien then I
don't yeah but I don't know his age is
the problem or just being in that Jersey
Shore House too long you're still done
you should be out by 40. I don't care if
you you know if you're 89 you got an 84.
that's fine
Jersey shorehouse
oh my God you got a Snooki out there
yeah whatever you guys want to do you
want to play Bingo you know like I don't
know what you're doing you know but
anyway so I don't know Elizabeth the guy
give you a little pushback right here
okay bring it my grandma's 92 years old
okay yeah I love my grandma to death
yeah okay I don't want her running the
country at this point Pat's dad is one
of the wisest men I know
how old is Papa now turned 81 last week
okay and I mean this sincerest way I
don't want him running the country I
want his son running the country young
healthy vibrant dedicated I want no I
agree Gabriel being the concern I agree
on the consiglier saying the age is not
the issue it's how long they've been
there yeah so you don't think it's both
so you're saying I think it's the 80s
and 90s and 100 year olds that are
running the country you want Hunter
Biden to run the country
and the White House got it okay no I
don't know what he's saying is he wants
the Santas Adam wants DeSantis or Newsom
even after the UFC
foreign
I'm not gonna lie that was kind of dope
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]